So I have multiple stories today about slurs
and epithets.
It wasn't just Donald Trump accused of it.
And we will look at that shortly.
It was also Donald Trump's friend, Roger Stone,
doing it on live radio, calling a black man
Negro during an interview.
Remember that?
Just days ago, Donald Trump commuted the prison
sentence of Roger Stone.
And it was another one of these powerful and
defiant shows of cronyism and corruption from
Donald Trump.
And incredibly, just days after having his
sentence commuted by Donald Trump, Roger Stone
calls into the Mr. Mo Kelly Show on Los Angeles
radio station KFI 640 a.m. and they're debating
Stone's conviction.
And at one point, Stone goes quiet and then
you hear him say, I don't really feel like
arguing with this Negro.
Check it out.
The line then goes dead.
But it's really not dead.
Roger Stone is just sitting there not saying
anything.
And then he eventually comes back and says,
no, I didn't I didn't say I didn't call you
a Negro.
Take a listen to this.
I don't know Sanders.
I my know.
I do believe that certain people are treated
differently in the federal justice system.
I do absolutely believe that.
But I also believe that your friendship and
relationship and history with Donald Trump
weighed more heavily than him.
Just wanted to make sure that justice was
done by a person in the justice system that
you were treated so unfairly.
There are thousands of people treated unfairly
daily how your number just happened to come
up in a lottery.
I'm guessing it was more than just luck.
Roger.
Right.
She was pregnant with the Spiegler.
I'm sorry that.
I'm sorry, what did you say?
I'm sorry you argued with him.
I thought we were having just a very spirited
conversation.
What happened?
Would you not like to continue the conversation,
sir?
I hear that the line is not dead.
You're back.
I don't know what that.
Well, yeah, yeah, I was talking and you said
something about Negroes, I wasn't exactly
sure.
I did not hear how your mind.
Your mind.
I will.
OK, well, we'll let the listeners decide.
Let me go to the next question then.
Whatever.
And Roger Stone just sticking with that explanation,
just insisting he never set it stone again,
denied making the comment in a statement given
to the Christian Broadcasting Network.
Yeah, it's as funny as it sounds, claiming
that there was cross talk and it made it difficult
to know who said what.
Which, of course, is not the case.
It is perfectly silent at the time that he
says it.
And you hear the phrase very, very clearly
and the word Negro even more clearly.
Take a look at she was arguing with this Negro.
I'm sorry.
There must have been gremlins in the phone
line or a hacker or someone who, right when
Roger Stone went quiet, was able to intercept
the phone call and insert the word Negro into
the communication.
Right.
Would that maybe be a more believable explanation?
And when I listen back to it, the most obvious
part about it for me is if the phone really
broke up and Roger Stone couldn't hear anything
for a while and hadn't called the host a Negro,
he would have been really confused and flummoxed
and outraged by the accusation that he said
Negro.
He just immediately denied saying it, like
if I was being interviewed and for 30 seconds,
I couldn't hear anything.
And then when I can hear the host again, the
coach says, you just said something about
a Negro.
I would say, what?
What on earth are you talking about?
I've said nothing for 30 seconds.
I've never called the black person a Negro.
And I have no clue what you're talking about.
Sterling's reaction is to say, no, I didn't
I didn't call you a Negro.
It's almost Orwellian, like you can't trust
what you hear.
And then, you know, pretending the line was
seemingly dead when it wasn't.
There's just not that much more to say here.
This is exactly the type of people that Trump
has around him.
It's a pretty simple analysis.
Not everybody who supports Trump is racist,
obviously.
But the racists overwhelmingly support Trump
and he has many of them around him.
And that's sort of it.
You know, I don't want to be arguing with
a Negro that it's there plain as day.
This is clearly how Roger Stone grew up, referring
to black people.
Sometimes people are just racist.
You know, there are times for more precision.
Are we?
Is this an instance of prejudice or are we
talking about systemic versus personal racism
or is someone insensitive or whatever?
This is just a racist guy who says racist
things and he got caught and that's it.
It's very much in line with the Trump administration
technique of sometimes they do something crazy
and then they just deny that it happened.
Trump said fifteen cases would go to zero.
Well, you know, Foushee at one point said,
don't wear a mask, then that's no good.
And then they just move on and they go to
the next thing.
This is the guy that Roger Stone commuted
the sentence for just a few days ago and immediately
out there arguing with radio hosts and referring
to them as Negroes.
That's what it is.
Now we'll go from stone
to Trump.